DANNY HERMES: I'm Danny Hermes,
a member of developer
relations here at Google.
I work on commerce, as
many of you know.
And we're here to talk
today about the
content API for Shopping.
And, in particular, we have two
guests to talk about the
Google Affiliate Network and
product listing ads.
So right next to me
is Claire Hugo.
She works on PLAs here in
Mountain View with me.
And in the pink shirt, I'll let
him introduce himself, is
Mark Coppin from Chicago,
to talk about GAN.
So to start us off, Mark
has a few words to say.
And then we'll be fielding
questions from you guys.
So, Mark?
MARK COPPIN: Sure,
thanks Danny.
I'm Mark Coppin.
I'm a manager on the Google
Affiliate Network.
We are a cost-per-acquisition,
or
cost-per-sale, advertising network.
It's a little different pricing
model than CPC or CPM.
And the relevant piece here is
that we also use content, or
products, that advertisers are
submitting to Merchant Center,
and make those available to our
publishers through publish
fees and the content API.
So I thought I'd join and see
if anyone had any questions
about our product.
DANNY HERMES: So if you guys
can't think of anything right
now, I can get Mark to come
back another time.
I know you guys have some other
concerns about some of
the announcements.
But if you have questions right
now, then Mark is a
great resource.
So anybody have anything they're
curious about with
Google Affiliate Network?
JOHN: Yeah, sorry
it's John here.
Mark, could you just spend two
minutes just walking through
what the process is and how ads
get tied up with content
feed, if you don't mind
please, Mark.
MARK COPPIN: Sure, so our
publishers join our network.
They actually have to have an
AdSense account because we pay
through AdSense.
But once a publisher has joined
our network they can
apply to work with specific
advertisers.
So one thing that's a little
unique about the affiliate
advertising space compared to,
say, display networks, is
that-- sorry there's
some construction
going on around here--
is that publishers choose what
advertisers they want to work
with and what ads they would
like to run on their site.
In a lot of cases, the content
on a publisher's site is the
actual ads.
You can think of like a loyalty
model or a coupon site
that's aggregating
coupon content or
products on their site.
That is more the typical
affiliate business model than,
say, I just want to put an ad
tag on my site and let a
network fill it and do yield
optimization for me.
A lot of affiliate publishers
are doing their own yield
optimization and content
aggregation.
So specific to the content
API, you can think of
publishers that are creating
virtual shopping experiences.
They're comparing products, are
letting consumers compare
products on their site, and then
sending those consumers
off to the advertiser's site
for, hopefully, a conversion.
So compare prices, and colors,
and descriptions,
and stuff like that.
And then send that traffic to a
Kohl's to actually purchase
a product and then earn a
commission on that purchase.
So that's sort of the more
typical business model for an
affiliate publisher.
DANNY HERMES: Thanks.
Does anybody have any
other questions?
All right, thanks Mark.
We do have some questions for
me Andrew Lamonica in his
absence today.
But he sent them to me when he
heard we were going to be
talking a bit about ads and
the Affiliate Network.
So Mark, if you want to
head out, feel free.
Otherwise, if you want to stick
around, we would love to
have you for further input.
So the first question from
Andrew, how, if at all, does
including AdWords PLAs affect
normal Google Product Search
visibility?
For example, if he Googles
"funny yellow mechanical
pencil" and the PLA for his
oddly-specific product shows
up, will that prevent his
product from also showing up
in Shopping results module
in Natural Search?
So, Claire?
CLAIRE HUGO: So PLAs do not
affect an item showing up in
Google Product Search.
And so if you're promoting
a product through product
listing ads and then also
through Product Search, then
you have the opportunity to
show in both channels.
DANNY HERMES: Thank you.
As a follow up--
actually, do you want to
restate this question?
CLAIRE HUGO: The second one?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
CLAIRE HUGO: OK, so the second
question was about the seller
reviews that show alongside
Product Search results.
So, in some cases, some
companies have that available,
and some do not.
And so this question is more
specific to Product Search.
And if you go to the Google
Merchant Help Center and
search on seller ratings,
there's a full article about
how we will automatically crawl
third-party review sites
and then match those ratings
for our results.
And if they're not appearing
for a particular merchant,
there is some information there
on how to research that
and how to escalate sale.
And those can be reviewed
as well.
DANNY HERMES: OK, so it's sort
of a third party combined with
also some other input from
the merchants themselves.
So another question from Andrew
was about errors.
So if there are products that
are disapproved for Product
Ads, but not disapproved
for Product Search,
how can they tell?
Will this show up in the
data quality section?
Or is there some other place
that they should be going to
find out about these errors?
CLAIRE HUGO: So if there are
items that are disapproved for
our Product Listing Ads, that
should typically be listed in
the Data Quality tab.
For example, if an item has a
trademarked term in the title,
and it's disapproved for the
trademark, then that would be
apparent on that Data
Quality tab.
There's also information on the
Products tab where we have
two columns, one for
Product Search and
one for Product Ads.
So you're able to see a green
check mark if it's approved
for Product Search.
And then, say, the item was
disapproved for a trademark,
then you would see the red
circle for Product Ads.
And on the Data Quality
tab is a good
place to see the summaries.
You can see 5%, or the number
of items disapproved for a
particular reason.
But on the Products tab is
where you can see for
individual products.
DANNY HERMES: Great, and Andrew
also says that this is
a feature that he's interested
in, and some of
you might be as well.
Since a product initially starts
out as disapproved for
Product Ads and then has to be
matched with a campaign, he
says it would be nice to have
a way where he could filter
out and find out which
ones had been
matched and which hadn't.
And that's something we're
certainly going to take as
good feedback and pass
along to the team.
And a final question he has,
which is, again, sort of
speculative or a future request,
is, are there any
plans to add a performance
table for PLAs?
Or is there another place
where we can see
that existing data?
CLAIRE HUGO: So right now for
Product Listing Ads, the best
way to see performance
data is to look
in the AdWords interface.
And there you can see
impressions, clicks,
clickthrough rates, spend,
conversion data if you have
Conversion Tracking
implemented.
And we are making a lot
of improvements to the
Performance tab in Merchant
Center as well.
Hopefully you've noticed that
over the past couple months.
And I would expect to see
more improvements in the
short term as well.
DANNY HERMES: Great.
Great answers, and in absentia,
great questions, Andrew.
So now for the people actually
on the call, do you guys have
any questions for Claire or
Mark, PLA questions for
Claire, or [? organic ?]
questions for Mark?
Or questions for me?
LUKE: Is it OK if I ask, could
you just explain in a nutshell
again what I was reading in the
announcement about how--
my understanding about, are all
product listings now for
Google Product Search going to
be part of the AdWords system?
You're saying you have to be
submitted through Content API,
but then they have to match
something in AdWords in order
to be able to be listed
in Product Search?
Could you explain how that's
going to work?
CLAIRE HUGO: Sure, so with the
new shopping experience that
we'll be launching in October,
it will require that the
Merchant Center have a linked
AdWords account and have a
campaign live with product
listing ads in order to show
in our Shopping property.
So that means you can continue
on with it, the feed, or using
the API as normal on the
Merchant Center side.
But then each account will
need to have that AdWords
account linked, and a bid for
each of the products to be
promoting it.
LUKE: So does that mean that
once the Content API uploads a
product-- let's just
say it's a new
product you've just posted--
it's going to show up in the
AdWords interface under PLA?
CLAIRE HUGO: So there's a
few ways you can do it.
On the AdWords side, you can
create an ad group, or
campaign, to promote
all products from
your Merchant Center.
So that means anytime you add a
new product on the Merchant
Center side, it will
automatically be matched to
that All Products target
in the AdWords account.
You can also get more granular
with the PLA campaign.
So if you want to bid
differently for different set
of products, then you can
have a target just for
your payroll products.
And then you can also have
that All Products target.
So in that case, you have
apparel where you want bid $1,
and then you have the
All Products where
you want to bid $0.50.
And that way you still have full
coverage for everything
that's being submitted through
Merchant Center.
LUKE: Is there going to
be minimum bidding
required for those ads?
Because I'm just imagining a
situation where if you haven't
met the minimum bid for a given
product, it wouldn't
show up at all, right?
CLAIRE HUGO: Right, so every
time you have a Product
Listing Ad, it will
enter an auction.
And the minimum bid is
going to be $0.01.
With that said, if you're
bidding that low, it's
possible that the traffic
will be really low.
So it's a matter of
understanding the products
that are being promoted, the
competition, and finding that
sweet spot where it's profitable
for the advertiser,
and you're getting the traffic
that you're interested in.
LUKE: So you can set up an Ad
Group that has, say, some
spending limit, like is
it per month, I guess?
CLAIRE HUGO: You
can do per day.
LUKE: OK, per day.
Right, per day.
And then they could put in some
upper bid amount as a
Product Group?
And then as the Content API
submits these products, as
long as they come in under that
daily spend, it will keep
showing those ads, wherever
they land
based on the auction?
CLAIRE HUGO: Yes, exactly.
DANNY HERMES: So Dani in the
chat is asking for a
clarification.
She asks, even if an advertiser
is the only
advertiser, is it possible that
the products won't show
up if the bid's too low?
CLAIRE HUGO: If the product had
a bid associated with it,
and it's the only item that's
eligible for the query, then
it should show in that case.
So that's why we're encouraging
advertisers to
promote all of their products,
even with a low bid.
And then we also have an
incentive program that can be
found through the Commerce Blog,
or the Inside AdWords
Blog, where you can get a $100
coupon for AdWords for new PLA
advertisers.
And if you promote all products,
then you can get 10%
of your PLA spend credited to
your account every month
through the end of the year.
DANNY HERMES: OK, great,
super helpful.
So John is asking-- and John,
Dani is asking Chet because
she doesn't have mic.
But if you want to ask with
your microphone, you can.
Or I can read it, either one.
JOHN: Yeah, it's just
a quick question.
How does this tie in with
multi-client accounts.
DANNY HERMES: So I've actually
been looking at some internal
conversations about this.
This isn't 100% clear yet.
I don't know if Claire has
any insights on it.
If not, then we'll certainly
update you as we know more
internally.
Do you?
CLAIRE HUGO: Yeah, that's
something I would want to
follow up on to make
sure [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: Right, from what
I understand, you can,
programmatically, using API's,
connect each sub-account with
a different campaign.
But I don't have a really good
understanding from a technical
standpoint, or from a sort of
account rules, and things like
that, standpoint.
So I don't want to give you
any false information yet.
But the conversations are
being had internally.
And that is one of the main
workflows that needs to be
ironed out.
So thanks for the question,
and we'll try to
get a better answer.
LUKE: So Danny, what you're
saying is that, in terms of
linking the Content API
products, as we submit them
through this AdWords link,
that's going to be
to-be-determined right now.
Because you said earlier the
AdWords account was going to
be connected to the MCA account
some kind of way, in
an automated way, [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: So there's some
other details there, like you
may want each of your individual
sellers to have
their own individual AdWords
account that they manage or
that they give you some
settings through your
interface that you send through
to manage, rather than
having a single account
associated with MCA that is a
catch all for everybody.
For large marketplaces, that
model probably doesn't make a
whole lot of sense because you
have, all across the spectrum,
different kinds of sellers.
You have big sellers
and small sellers.
You have sellers that have big
marketing budgets and have
small marketing budgets.
And then you just have sellers
that are probably selling
different kinds of products with
different bid levels that
are found out in the actual
auctioning on a regular basis.
So there are a lot of details
there and a lot of tiny pieces
in the big machine
to figure out.
So, like I said, there is a
conversation being had.
And it's not 100% decided or
determined what the way to go
about it is.
But, certainly, in the simple
case, you can still associate
an AdWords account with
the parent MCA.
And that will propagate across
to everyone, but there's a lot
more involved.
LUKE: Is that documented
somewhere?
DANNY HERMES: Not
that I know of.
Is it in the Merchant
Center docs?
In our docs, we certainly don't
get into any of that.
CLAIRE HUGO: I don't think we
have it right now, as far as
the MCA structure
and the linkage.
But that's something I can
[? work list ?] and share with
the content team.
DANNY HERMES: Certainly, and
feedback from guys like you,
top contributors to our forums
and things like that,
important members of our
community, they're
things we listen to.
And work that we put out for
ourselves to make documents if
there is something that there's
a resounding voice
saying it's not clear, then
we want it to be clear.
And we want to clear it up.
So keep giving that feedback if
you see something you think
should be documented
and isn't.
LUKE: There is an AdWords
API, right?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, I don't
know a whole lot about it.
But certainly there are APIs for
many different pieces of
the AdWords, DoubleClick,
et cetera.
And very similar, if not better
support, with client
libraries, and things like,
and documentation for the
client libraries.
They're relatively similar.
But I'm not sure if they're
API or GData APIs.
There is a little bit difference
in the client
libraries when you go from
one to the other.
But in either case .NET will
be supported 100%, Luke.
LUKE: OK, cool.
Is there somebody like you in
their division we can talk to?
DANNY HERMES: There are much
bigger teams in Dev Rel.
They have many more than me.
They have three, four, five,
for each particular aspect
that you would consider.
So yeah, there is
AdWords Dev Rel.
There is a DoubleClick
Dev Rel.
There's all kinds of things.
There are even Dev Rels specific
to Androids, specific
to iOS, et cetera.
AdMob, there we go.
That's the thing I couldn't
think of.
But yeah, they are a part of
Dev Rel, and they are a
relatively big team.
If you go to
developers.google.com/events,
you can actually see when
they're doing their office
hours because it will
be on the schedule.
And if you want to post a
question on the forum about
what their forums are, I can
reach out to some of those
team members and find the
best places for you to--
LUKE: Can you give me
that address again?
What was that URL?
DANNY HERMES:
developers.google.com/events.
LUKE: Slash events.
Gotcha.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
that's where we
post all of our events.
So does anybody have any
other questions?
Or did we sort of run out of
questions about PLAs, and the
integration, and the
announcement,
and things like that?
Looks like Dani is typing
a question.
Or maybe she's typing to
say no more questions.
She says that she's
trying to set up a
new PLA ad from scratch.
She made an AdGroup.
And I bet there's a question
coming after.
And on the new ad she sees--
I'm going to wait until she's
done and then just summarize.
CLAIRE HUGO: [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: OK.
OK, so she says she's
trying to set up a
new PLA from scratch.
She made a new AdGroup.
And on the new ad, she sees
some text, an image, an
AdBuilder, and a WAP.
Not sure what that it.
And she wants to know which
one she should choose to
actually make a PLA.
CLAIRE HUGO: So when you're
setting up a PLA, you want to
first extend the campaign
settings to promote products
for Merchant Center.
So--
DANNY HERMES: We can actually
share our screen, if you want.
And you can do this.
And they can watch what
you're doing.
Would you want to do that?
CLAIRE HUGO: Do you have an
AdWords test account?
DANNY HERMES: I don't, but we
can open an incognito window,
and you can sign
in with yours.
I don't know if it would be--
CLAIRE HUGO: No, I can't.
DANNY HERMES: How about this,
I'll invite you to the
Hangout, and you do it
from your machine.
OK?
All right, technical
issue here.
We're going to add one
more participant.
We're going to actually
add Claire's account.
I think she's already been
invited, but I will make sure.
Great question, Dani, and
there's nothing better than a
live demo during a Hangout.
CLAIRE HUGO: I don't actually
have the login.
DANNY HERMES: Gotcha.
So, Luke, have you had a chance
to check out the new
docs that I published
since we last spoke?
LUKE: Yeah I did.
They're excellent.
DANNY HERMES: What do
you think of the
new API for the library?
In this case, the interface for
the library, rather than
the actual online API.
Much more intuitive, right?
LUKE: Yeah, I think you
did a great job.
It's excellent.
DANNY HERMES: Thank you.
And I'm a Python developer.
I pretty much tried to make
it as Pythonic as I could.
And it's nice--
you know, Python, you can't have
different signatures for
the same function.
But I kind of like that
in .NET and then
other compiler languages.
It's a cute little language,
though I don't like compiling
all the time.
So I'll going to stick with
my dynamic languages
on a regular basis.
But we're trying--
we don't have a writer on
our team right now.
But we're trying to do to
improve on those a bit more,
and combine them into a single
document, and just sort of
have a choice where you
pick what language,
and things like that.
But there's also some MCA and
data feeds functionality in
those libraries that is
there but just not
documented as well.
So we're trying to sort of
balance that workload with I/O
preparation, which is quite
intense right now.
So I don't know that we'll
see that before July.
But it's something that's
certainly on our horizon.
Do you want to just do that all
of this in the Hangout?
CLAIRE HUGO: Let me see if
this will work, actually.
DANNY HERMES: OK, we want to
make sure it works before we
actually show it.
John, I looked into getting
a Raspberry Pi.
And it is on my "that's
interesting" list. I don't
know if it's quite on my
to-do list just yet.
But it's something I've looked
into since you suggested it
about a month ago, or whenever
you brought that up.
Python for Education, yeah.
Claire is an AdWords wiz.
I can't believe it.
CLAIRE HUGO: It's just I have
the account set up, so I can't
look at my test account unless
I access ICS, which
I can't just by--
DANNY HERMES: Right.
CLAIRE HUGO: Can I just
talk through this?
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
CLAIRE HUGO: OK, because I can't
show a portion of this
window, right?
DANNY HERMES: No, you cannot.
CLAIRE HUGO: OK.
Sorry about that.
DANNY HERMES: OK, so Claire
doesn't think she can get a
demo with enough information
redacted
for it to be showable.
So she's just going to talk
through some of the settings.
CLAIRE HUGO: Yeah, so once
you're in the AdWords
interface, when you're creating
a new campaign, or
editing an existing
campaign, if you
click into that campaign--
so click on the name either
in the left nav or on the
Campaigns tab in the center.
And then click on the
Settings tab.
And if you scroll down, you
should see an option to extend
the campaign with items from
Google Merchant Center.
And this will only happen after
you have linked your
Merchant Center account with
your AdWords account.
So if I can just back up one
step, within the Merchant
Center account, if you click on
the Settings tab, and then
it will expand, and you can
click on the AdWords link.
And then add your 10-digit
customer ID
from the AdWords account.
And once you've done this, then
in the AdWords account,
you'll see on that Campaign
Settings tab the option to
extend with products from your
Merchant Center account.
So once you've selected that
box, when you are in the new
AdGroup, or the existing
AdGroup, and you click on
Create a New Ad, among the
options that Danny already
listed, you'll see the
option to create a
Product Listing Ad.
DANNY HERMES: Awesome.
CLAIRE HUGO: And there's also
actually a video that goes
through all of these steps.
And that's at--
DANNY HERMES: I can link to the
video in my G+ stream, in
the forum summary of this
video, as well as in the
YouTube comments, or excuse me,
the YouTube description of
this video.
So we will get that you
guys after the fact.
But I don't think reading it
aloud will be that helpful,
though putting in chat
that might be.
But thanks for the
question, Dani.
I think that was a
good question.
And the demo I saw was pretty
cool over here.
Sorry you guys couldn't
see it.
If there are no more questions,
we'll wrap up
before 11:00, like
we usually do.
But I will allow the floor to be
open for questions one last
time, going once.
LUKE: Let me ask just one more
thing about impressions data.
Was impressions data still
on the list for--
DANNY HERMES: It is.
It's, as I found out, something
that is easy to do,
though it's not something that
is necessarily something we
want to do.
So it's not a yes or no.
It's in discussion.
Well, easy-- that's probably not
the right way to put it.
But it is still on
our radar, and it
is still being discussed.
And I'll update that bug if it
does get added and certainly
update the documentation.
LUKE: OK.
DANNY HERMES: So Dani
is typing something.
OK so it's another PLA AdWords
interface question.
This is for Merchant
Center, or?
CLAIRE HUGO: That's AdWords,
the Product Extension tab.
So within AdWords there is
an Ad Extensions tab.
But where you want to set up
the Product Listing Ads is
actually on the Auto
Targets tab.
So on the Merchant Center
option, it looks like she's
seeing her ID and
company name.
And so that would display when
you're linking the campaign to
the Merchant Center account.
And so it sounds like she may
be seeing different Merchant
Center accounts listed there,
which may be the case if
there's a multi-client
account involved.
So--
she still typing.
DANNY HERMES: The power
of microphones.
LUKE: So Danny, as far as we
know, we can't, through the
content API, add the
AdWords customer ID
under MCA yet, right?
DANNY HERMES: I'm not
sure about that.
I don't know in either
direction.
LUKE: OK, I mean, eventually
we'll want that, right?
DANNY HERMUS: Yeah, there have
been talks for some more
features in the content API
that give a tighter
integration between the two.
LUKE: Yeah, because I'm trying
to automate it, right?
So I don't want it to manually
do it, so OK.
DANNY HERMES: Right.
So Dani is asking--
she sees multiple extensions
from a single account.
But there are already
extensions, and they
have the same name.
And she's curious which one
is the correct one.
But I think without actually
seeing the account it would be
a bit unclear as to what
she's looking at.
Is that correct?
CLAIRE HUGO: Yeah, if they're
all the same account ID, than
you should just be able to
choose one of those.
But it would probably
be easier to look at
the specific account.
DANNY HERMES: Dani, if you're
comfortable sharing your
screen, we may be
able to help.
I don't know that that's
something you want to do.
Actually, you know, let's
hold off on that.
But are there any particular
forums that you recommend
asking questions like this or
any particular things that
people should be searching
for or looking for?
CLAIRE HUGO: Yeah, if there are
PLA-secific questions, I
would ask a question to
the AdWords forum.
And then if it's on the Merchant
Center side, there's
the merchant forum.
So in either case, we'll be able
to field and point users
in the right direction.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
All right, Dani says thanks.
So that looks like it's going
to be it for us today.
Thanks a ton to Claire.
And thanks to Mark for the
introduction you gave. I'm
sorry, Mark, we couldn't feed
more questions your way.
But our guests were phenomenal
today, and it was
great to have them.
It certainly makes my morning
a bit easier.
Everybody be well.
Our next time we meet will
not be in two weeks.
It will be in four weeks because
two weeks is Google
I/O, and I will be
super-duper busy.
So four weeks, well, I don't
know the exact date.
So I'm not going to
say a wrong one.
I actually said an incorrect
one for our last Hangout.
And also, I found we're
being moved again.
Last time, it was from
Wednesdays to Tuesdays.
Next one will be on a Thursday,
but I will certainly
give ample time and may have
another guess then, as well,
maybe a PM or the tech lead
on the engineering team.
But maybe it'll be just me.
But thanks, everybody.
Have a nice day, or night,
in John's case.
Dani, I'm not sure what time
zone you're coming from.
But Mark, have a
nice afternoon.
I know it's already afternoon
in Chicago.
See everybody later, and
thanks, everybody, for
watching on YouTube as well.
CLAIRE HUGO: Thanks guys.